so let's just start off
um you know you've often said that your
mission is to eliminate small talk so
I'm wondering how that became important
to you and what impact you think it's
going to have to eradicate small talk
yeah before anybody gets too angry I'll
clarify that for me Small Talk has
nothing to do with the content of a
conversation it has to do with the
process and so I have had a conversation
about the weather that I would
absolutely put in the category of
conversation that mattered deeply it
happened to be with a man named Eugene
Claudio who is a meteorologist and we
were studying seasonal affective
disorder but the idea is like you can
talk about the weather if the process if
you're really curious about it if it
matters Etc and so I got clear a few
years ago on this kayak camping retreat
in the middle of nowhere Maine and the
intention was to kind of Disconnect from
the world reconnect with yourself
and some higher purpose if you believe
there even is one and very much to my
surprise on that trip I got really
crystal clear language that was Chad you
exist to gently eradicate small talk and
create conversations that matter and
after that all these like little flashes
of
um notable historical figures showed up
for me and so can you imagine like
Buddha or Gandhi or Rosa Parks or Jesus
or anybody else uh who like has made
history in some way walking up to you
and saying how was your weekend I'm sure
they did it right I'm I'm totally I'm
sure that all of them at some point
asked a question like that but I think
the people in my life who like really
change things and shift things have a
way of cutting to the heart of what
matters
um and so you know a mentor of mine uh
Jeff 15 minutes before I got married
walked straight up to me no niceties no
hellos put his hand on my shoulder and
just said are you present because you
really don't want to miss your own
wedding
and 10 years ago I'm really glad he did
that because I was actually there and so
I think
um a couple to answer your question like
specifically and concretely I think we
could probably double the amount of good
stuff that happens in the world if we
cut out like idle Chit Chat just because
now I still think you can ask how are
you what do you do where are you from
all these questions and have it matter
but I think it's also interesting to
note like we're we get in such a routine
with the questions we ask that just by
disrupting those questions a little bit
we tend to ask better questions because
they're more intentional they're more
thoughtful we're not just like plugging
the cassette in and just letting the
tape play and when we move off of
autopilot
that's useful
um I'm really curious about the role of
trust in eradicating small talk right
because if you hadn't met me and I came
up to you 10 minutes before your wedding
and said are you present you're like
you're in my way okay I'm on the way the
runway get out of the way right so
um curious your thoughts about that so
let's let's go back to that scenario
um let's pretend we hadn't met which we
hadn't 10 years ago and let's pretend
you crashed my wedding and you walked up
to me I think it's an interesting
hypothetical experiment to think about
how could you ask that same question and
have it be received well I guess it's
just an interesting thought experiment
and I wonder and this is what uh the
first chapter of ask powerful questions
focuses in on is being clear about your
intent and sharing it with the person
that it affects
and so if I if you didn't know me and
you crashed my wedding and you walked up
to me you said hey I recognize I've got
a question for you and I recognize this
a little bit strange because we haven't
met yet but when I got married it was
really really useful when somebody else
asked me this question can I ask it
right so I've like shared a really clear
intent it's framed in the benefit of the
other and I've also seeked consent and
all before I asked that like that bigger
question and so if you do those things
what might happen is they choose to not
play the game and they're like no please
don't ask me this question or they
choose to like
curl up or back off in some way
um
but I think
people are more willing to answer
difficult unusual curiosity based
questions if if you're clear about your
intent and you ask them for permission
uh first so that said yeah it's a lot
easier to just go for it if you have a
relationship of trust already
established with somebody but being
clear about your intent and seeking
their permission builds trusts
as quick as I know how because you're
not gonna like walk up to somebody and
read them your bio and be like see I'm
not a serial killer yeah
text is everything isn't it right I mean
you understand
important